cinquante ans avant le mouvement
il était déjà prêt à se battre contre le
racisme idéal qui eux
que tous les peuples du monde pour rire
côte à côte la cause des noix on avait
toujours été nous sensibiliser au delà
de la couleur il y à une solidarité
d'aubry mais l'histoire a surtout une
action violente du effectué les bons la
mort de pierre laporte un communiqué du
effectué annonce que le ministre du
travail a été assassiné et que son corps
était déposé dans le coffre à bagages de
la voiture ayant servi à son enlèvement
cette semaine grâce à des témoignages
inédits et des documents d'archivés
exceptionnelles on découvre en effet le
cul qu'on connaît beaucoup moins celui
de felquistes qui étaient engagés dans
une révolution mondiale et pour eux la
fin justifier les moyettes veille la
révolution socialiste québécois et
international le flq ici marie maude
denis
bienvenue à aucun
[Musique]
subtilité une sorte de 11 septembre
version 1965
[Musique]
un incroyable complot pour détruire les
symboles les plus forts des états unis
la statue de la liberté
la cloche de la liberté de philadelphie
et l'obélisque de washington seul
l'infiltration de la cellule terroriste
par la police a permis d'enrayer le
complot les coupables sont membres d'une
cellule du black liberation front un
groupuscule afro américain clandestin
parmi les conspirateurs les américains
découvrent avec étonnement cette
québécoise
michel duclos et les speakerines à la
télévision au canal 10 à montréal
[Musique]
elle est aussi militante du jeune parti
souverainiste le rassemblement pour
l'indépendance nationale le hérie m
c'est elle qui a transporté depuis
montréal
de la dynamite provenant de l'arsenal du
front de libération du québec le
terrorisme québécois vient de faire son
entrée sur la scène internationale
[Musique]
à montréal les premières banques du
véhicule font des ravages depuis deux
ans
[Musique]
les premières cibles de son associé à l'
empire britannique et aux institutions
canadiennes statue de la reine victoria
boîte aux lettres caserne militaire
leur but secouer l'apathie des québécois
et les conduire à l'indépendance il voit
le québec comme une colonie
m
il s'inspire directement de la guerre de
décolonisation de l'algérie contre la
france
l'indépendance de l'algérie obtenu en
1962 suscite un courant sympathie au
québec chez les musulmans d'algérie est
apparu ce phénomène centrale de l'après
guerre le nationalisme nationalisme
intraitable et viet impitoyable des
hommes qui ont vécu longtemps sur la
domination d'autrui
michel duclos sera en algérie en 1963 de
retour elle confie à des amis rêver
d'une lutte québécoise sur un mode
algérien
elles se sentent aussi solidaires du
mouvement des droits civiques des noirs
américains alors en pleine effervescence
comme elle le confiait à une journaliste
de photos journal toutes les servitudes
économiques ou sociales ne sont sortir
de mon tempérament
le sociologue jean philippe maurer a
beaucoup étudié la mouvance du flq des
années 1960 et son ambition de
participer à la révolution mondiale
c'est pas une grande surprise de voir
que lorsqu'ils se rencontrent ces
jeunes-là à alger à paris à lavable à
new york à san francisco et commencent à
débattre mais se dit que finalement on
partage beaucoup de choses on a beaucoup
de valeurs en commun pour qu'on pourrait
pas s'unir pour faire en sorte que
demain la société qu'on habite soit
libérés soit expurgé des impressions des
exploitations qui l'a mené dans ce
moment
[Musique]
michel duclos avait des complices au
québec notamment son ami michel saulnier
saunier est une pasionaria des débuts du
pml a connu le chef du black liberation
front à cuba lors d'une rencontre
internationale de jeunes sympathisants
de la révolution c'est elle qui a fait
découvrir à robert collier l'existence
du flq et de son arsenal d'explosifs
cet arsenal est composée de centaines de
bâtons de dynamite voler sur des
chantiers de construction en particulier
ceux du métro de montréal
[Musique]
coolio se rend à montréal pour
rencontrer les deux québécoises avec un
autre militant ron wood
mais il ignore que woods est en réalité
un agent de la police de new york
infiltré dans son groupe qu'il observe
discrètement du plô veut se vouer corps
et âme à la révolution
quand on veut être révolutionnaire il ne
faut pas céder aux passions de l'amour
dans une révolution
les aventures sentimentales passe en
dernier
[Musique]
malgré cet engagement exalté michel du
peloton sous le charme de raimon woods
l'agent police celui ci sera bien placé
pour observer la suite des choses
duclos contacter un sympathisant du flq
gille 2 go qui joue un rôle de soutien
dans diverses actions du réseau
clandestin est entre année parce que
tous ses amis total et tu appelles
christ nous avons retrouvé la veuve de
ce militant encore émue au souvenir de
son premier amour
il m'appelait son p'tit kawa j'appelais
mon petit coeur pillet en tacot les
politesses autobus de partout on allait
là
mise au parfum du complot dans lequel
son mari j'ai legault et michel duclos
trempe elle pressent la catastrophe
annoncée
gdj qu'est-ce que tu n'as pas tout à
berck zibello dit le besoin de dynamite
c'est pour aller faire sauter les stops
sundberg le génie c'est complètement
insensé
là j'ai la version avant de partir du
paped avec michèle et gilles sauf si vos
pays bout c'est très très grave
laisse tomber
mais gilles legault il voit une occasion
à saisir le vix est une bonne occasion
donne la dynamique les américains
donnent des armes
c'est un boulot
et c'était aussi pour le gault
l'expression d'une solidarité la cause
des noirs on avait toujours été nous
sensibiliser duclos et legault
poursuivre l'opération
il récupère 68 bâtons de dynamite
c'est michel duclos qui fait la
livraison à new york étant dans le piège
trahi par mahmoud le policier qu'elle
croit être son complice le réseau est
démantelé
michel duclos fra 7 mois de prison
à montréal sony est aussi appréhendé
avec trois complices dont gilles de
gauche celui de gauche comme celle sont
ils
ici mais savourer j'ai loupé l'autre
côté celui qu'avait la dynamite
après avoir signé une confession gilles
legault est retrouvé pendu dans sa
cellule à la prison de bordeaux les
autorités conclu au suicide
une explication contestée par la famille
donc en tant que part ça ça vous laisse
des traces amer
je n'ai pas de souhaits truchère nez de
plus grand désir que d'entrer au québec
michel duclos a refait sa vie au liban
comme présentatrice de télévision et
animatrice de spectacles à beyrouth
c'est là que radio-canada la retrouver
en 1968
je suis pas un terroriste des environs
de la terreur et j'ai horreur du sang et
des choses qui font peur j'ai simplement
senti le besoin de faire du bruit
ledit statut qui tombe mois pensé que ça
pouvait plus déjà on y faire du mal à
quelqu'un quand on a 25 ans je pensais
qu'on a un peu dedans vision un peu
d'énergie et qu'on n'a pas été canalisée
dans une voie particulière il est normal
qu'on puisse s'égarer dans des chemins
la vaste majorité des gens qui ont
participé au flq et est jeune très jeune
20 ans 21 à 22 ans
des fois aussi jeune que 15 ans sait
déjà qu'ils étaient impatients on se
disait les choses ont pas si vite
ça prend des actions d'éclat ça prend
des coupes fort pour réveiller la
population de sa torpeur
[Musique]
après la pause effet le cube black
panthers même combat
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est un homme tranquille qui veut on
croire me ferait pas de mal à une mouche
a déjà été l'homme le plus recherché du
québec
[Musique]
la police et les médias ont donné son
nom de réseau jeu froid au plus
important groupe de poseurs de bombes du
flq
[Musique]
1968 la première six usines en grève de
seven up de ville mont royal où un
conflit pourri depuis huit mois
à noter
[Rires]
il aborda pas armés
placé c'est un des marais du matin de
mécanismes faire sauter la banque
on est nerveux on ne va pas donc la
poste on vient d'abord parce que ça a
prêté la salle à aider la cause
[Musique]
pas de morts mais il est tout de même
fait 27 blessés dont trois grièvement
dans l'attentât à la bourse de montréal
où placer hors jeunes dans des endroits
publics et fréquenté le saboteur qu'ils
étaient ils sont maintenant pas avec une
lâcheté anonyme à assumer le rôle de
meurtrier
c'était la pluie n'a pu marquer si c'est
bon signe et on vend des caillons pas
leur foi ou des foetus aux délices en
est à la bourse
c'est ça qui est l'air sous les 30 40
bon conomie par communiqué les auteurs
disent avoir voulu frapper un grand coup
au coeur du système capitaliste
les québécois doivent se libérer se
décoloniser et construire une société
nouvelle et un homme nouveau
selon les termes de che guevara
arrêté en 1969 pierre paul geoffroy
allait recevoir la plus sévère sentence
de tous les tribunaux du commonwealth
narre l'histoire 124 condamnation à
perpétuité
or il n'avait tué personne il sera
libéré douze ans plus tard
[Musique]
avec les réseaux de froid
le flq dépasse la cause purement et
dépendantes east il est aussi porte
étendard d'une révolution marxiste qui
se mène à l'échelle mondiale vietnam
palestine amérique latine
c'est le même combat la libération
véritable du peuple québécois est
possible seulement par la destruction du
de l'ordre impérialiste en amérique du
nord
les principaux responsables de cette
mutation
ce sont deux jeunes intellectuels pierre
vallières et charles gagnon se tous ces
deux là comme on fait que mr les ai
vécus davin des véhicules et à bercy
le québec fait partie du terme en le
mouvement de libération du québec
s'inscrit dans la pensée la plus mondial
qui puisse s'imaginer à l'heure actuelle
c'est à dire cet idéal qui veut que tous
les peuples du monde et toutes les
collectivités puissent vivre côte à côte
sans avoir à craindre de dominer par
d'odette écrasés par d'autres
[Musique]
de son côté car vallières l'autre leader
felquistes a écrit le texte le plus
emblématique de l'histoire du flq [ __ ]
blancs d'amérique
la comparaison entre le sort des
canadiens français et celui des noirs
américains est peut-être est discutable
mais à l'époque c'est un succès cent
mille copies vendues au québec
je pense ça parce que beaucoup vont se
sont reconnus et le message porte loin
ici en version allemande
on compte également des traductions en
anglais en espagnol et en italien
n'attendons pas de messie de solution
magique à nos problèmes
ce mot d'ordre ne peut venir que de nous
les [ __ ] blancs rouges noirs jaunes
les crottes et de la terre c'est en
prison à brooklyn en 1966 entouré de
prisonniers afro-américains cavaliere
l'avait écrit il venait de se faire
arrêter avec charles gagnon alors qu'ils
faisaient une grève de la faim devant
l'onu ce que nous comptons faire c'est
sur la lutte de libération se livre au
québec mais le but premier de leur
voyage à new york était de forger une
alliance avec les militants les plus
radicaux du black power américain
on ne peut pas fait le christ ou non ne
pas se sentir est interpellé par ce qui
se passe aux etats unis
ça brasse beaucoup ya des émeutes il ya
des quartiers entiers qui sont encerclés
par les forces de l'ordre parce que il
ya des révoltes qui s'y passe il ya mort
d'homme donc il ya vraiment quelque
chose d'important qui ce passe temps et
ça défraie la manchette
ici au québec chez les militants noirs
des années 1960
ce rapprochement est généralement
bienvenus philippe fils aimé un militant
américain d'origine haïtienne n'est aux
blancs d'amérique ce qu'est ce que c'est
pour moi
pour moi c'est une façon
pour les québécois de dire que on
reconnaît que les noirs ils sont
maltraités
nous aussi on est mal traitée au delà de
la couleur il y à une solidarité
d'opprimer fessée mais s'était réfugié à
montréal pour éviter la roulement
militaire pour le vietnam
deux jours après son arrivée des voisins
l'invite à la saint jean les
regrettables maintenant vol ce sera
drôle de fête
nous sommes en 1968
c'est ce jour qui sera rebaptisée lundi
de la matraque alors qu'une émeutes
sanglantes repose manifestants
séparatistes et policiers
je me suis dit tiens dire il ya
inversion ya de l'action dans ce pays
fessée mais se joint aux jeunes
mouvement du black power montréalais
alors qu'éclate l'occupation du campus
sur turgeon williams aujourd'hui
concordia pour dénoncer le racisme dans
cette université anglophone
au cours de cet événement marquant de
l'histoire des noirs au canada il
retrouve à ses côtés des felquistes
notamment français simard que l'on
aperçoit sur cette photo c'est un moment
de solidarité
c'est une recherche chez les québécois
tout le monde cherchait un peu noir
cherche identitaire
dans une entrevue au journaliste pierre
nadeau le leader du mouvement américain
des black panthers eldridge cleaver
réfugiés en algérie appuie sans réserve
lécher le cul rappeler c'est que les
doigts d'amérique étaient menés par un
certain nationalisme ça allait jusqu'à
même la volonté de bâtir une une nation
noire indépendante au coeur de
l'amérique
une délégation des black panthers ce
nouveau mouvement qui prône la lutte
armée
viet à montréal en 1968 clamé ce projet
d'une nation noire c'est la conférence
hémisphérique un rassemblement de
délégations de partout en amérique venus
réclamer la fin de la guerre du vietnam
le fondateur des black panthers bobby
seale partageait la tribune avec jacques
les rues l'endroit un pote tu essaies le
cul
[Applaudissements]
cette confiance-là a eu beaucoup
d'affluence le consensus s'était la
lutte la lutte nécessaire contre
l'impérialisme américaine
la rencontre est aussi l'occasion de
former une collaboration plus concret
entre les black panthers et le flq
ce qui va servir avant longtemps après
la pause les faits le cube kidnappé le
consul d'israël à montréal et voit le
but c'était de la tâche et là ma femme
l'a mauvaise
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
aucun pays aucune révolution ne vont
exercer sur la jeunesse mondiale
une fascination plus grande que la
révolution cubaine de 1959 aux côtés de
fidel castro
ernesto che guevara un argentin qui a
abandonné la médecine pour se consacrer
à son idéal révolutionnaire il fascine
la plaine est communiste convaincu il se
fait prophète d'une révolution mondiale
le problème de colonialisme et de
l'impérialisme qui pèsent sur le pays
oblige par cp rapport de deux mesures
vous lutté pour sa liberté pour guevara
venu ici à alger fraterniser avec ses
camarades algériens
les révolutions de tous les pays sont
des vases communicants l'armée nationale
populaire
[Applaudissements]
c'était un héros mythiques comme bien
d'autres le felquiste jacques lanctôt
ce rêve est un guevara pour moi c'était
quelqu'un qui avait affronté là bas et
on se dit ben comme dirait du bien de
venir au lavoir tddc a pourvu qu'il ne
trouva train de combattre contre les
injustices
c'était l'exemple à suivre ces détails
là il savait ce qui me liait les pays
tiers se libérer j'étais dans la
finition mais qu'à lui disait faut créer
d'autres cuba d'autres au vietnam mais
vous vous sentez concerné y avait une
clause à la mort grâce à venir océans
le flq fait partie de quelque chose de
plus grand qui explose dans tous les
coins de la planète brigades rouges en
italie
waterman aux états unis bande baader
meinhof en allemagne tout palmarès en
uruguay armée rouge japonaise
l'effet que d'un mouvement farouchement
nationaliste mais il est en solidarité
avec d'autres nationalisme partout sur
la planète tout ces gens là qui en ce
moment n'ont pas voix au chapitre au
besoin les uns des autres de s'épauler
dans une immense lutte à l'échelle du
globe pour faire advenir une société
plus juste et un sens non ya pas de
contradiction entre le fait d'être
nationaliste et le fait d'être
internationaliste à la fin de l'été 1969
les québécois apprennent par les
journaux que deux membres du flq ont
détourné un avion sur cuba il s'agit de
deux membres du réseau geoffroy alain
allard et pierre charette
nous avons rencontré pierre charette il
n'a pas voulu être filmée mais accepte
que l'on reproduit ses propos c'est à ce
moment là qu'on a pris l'addition j'ai
dit alain on se lève on était armé lui
avait son couteau et moi mon revolver
on n'était pas des héros on faisait ce
que la vie nous imposait
ils ont fui lé québec après
l'arrestation de leur camarade pierre
paul geoffroy pour se réfugier chez des
militants des black panthers à new york
ceux ci ne peuvent pas les garder nous
explique pierre charest et nous disaient
vous pouvez pas rester dans le même plan
comme vous êtes vous allé tout de suite
être identifié alors ils nous ont confié
à ces gens là
[Musique]
ces gens là ce sont des blancs militants
d'extrême gauche qui vivent dans une
commune plutôt libertaire
on arrive là dedans moi j'avais jamais
touché un joint de ma vie maison était
gelée pratiquement du matin on soit
arrivée dans l'appartement les filles
recevaient tenue c'était leur gîte total
nous prude une pudeur l'incroyable j'ai
même eu la première sensation d'être un
peu attardé mental
le leader du groupe sam melville et sa
partenaire principal jane halpert se
prennent d'affection pour les québécois
elle en a fait le récit dans son
autobiographie
j'étais touché par ces deux fugitifs
pierre etaix cheval reste envers les
femmes il était éloquent quand il
parlait de la discrimination envers les
francophones
il disait que l'indépendance était
inévitable et souviendrai possiblement
en moins de cinq ans
[Musique]
melville voulait tout apprendre des deux
québécois comment obtenir de la dynamite
comment fabriquer une bombe comment la
transporter ça ne pouvait rester avec
eux jusqu'à minuit à examiner des
diagrammes met à discuter
pierre charette devait son mentor
contribuant à sa radicalisation et à
celle de ses amis
je lui ai dit la société en question
arrêté de la condamnée démolissez l'a
fait quelque chose et ont compris
ces américains allaient devenir les
premiers waterman le groupe terroriste
le plus actif des années 1970 aux états
unis ça melville pause attend bombe à
new york en 1969 et 1970 qu'on surnomma
de matt bomer au québec cette année 70
est marqué par l'éveil du flq à la cause
palestinienne
il n'y a pas de distinction véritable
entre le mouvement de libération de la
palestine par exemple ou du vietnam
entre ces mouvements là et le mouvement
de libération québécois à montréal une
cellule passe à l'action
son plan kidnappé le consul d'israël
pierre marcil prixtel chauffeur de la
camionnette qu'est ce que vous aviez
dans ce véhicule
avaya va tout pour le
j'étais quelqu'un là il y avait des
arbres y avait un gros panier d'osier
plume de dans un but c'était de la tâche
est plus les matelas bancs tables
combien difficile qui est de l'époque
pierre mars il s'était engagé comme
soldats prêts à suivre dix ans - et
elles accueillent moins possible qu'est
ce que je sais pas que je vois pas mais
qui doit se fait tant mieux
posez pas trop de questions non on est
insatisfait l'été mais ça chauffe dans
le camion
l'architecte du complot c'était son
complice jacques lanctôt des
palestiniens bon ils sont ils n'ont pas
d'état donc un peu comme le peuple
québécois sont son territoire pour se
sentir plus de chanter victoire sa
culture donc été dépossédés
mais au moment de passer à l'action la
police les intercepts soi-disant à cause
d'un feu arrière défectueux sur leur
véhicule
un drôle de hasard c'est une bonne
question n'a pas encore revu avec
quelqu'un
dans l'orbité du flq crever alors un
personnage énigmatique un jeune militant
arabe sauve elle rachète carole devault
qui a été un formatrice de la police de
montréal dans le flq le garde à l'oeil
vous montrez vos photos castle elle
rachète avait pris d'un mois 1 février
61 sorel rached était un des principaux
propagandistes de la cause palestinienne
à montréal
vous avez des photos nues ok ok ok
impossible de photographier ce mobile
pourquoi il voulait pas se faire
photographier je n'ai pas été touchée
mais pas ça c'est jamais revendiqué
comme fait qui semait sympathisants de
communes était de plusieurs mouvements
internationaux et c'est ceci ou effet le
cul le temps d'une tentative ratée de
vol de dynamite en compagnie notamment
de carole devault cela dit je vais y
aller mais à condition que la moitié
vous me donnez de la moitié de la
dynamite
non il va faire quoi avec ça mais jamais
chou israël et disparus pas longtemps
après cette photo la soirée se présenter
chez lui quand il a quitté le canada
subitement comme fer
après la pause des felquistes au moyen
orient qui s'entraîne pour tuer mais
sélective assassiné au leader
[Musique]
le téléjournal de radio canada la sûreté
du québec vérifiera les informations
publiées par le magazine perspectives
selon lesquelles deux anciens membres du
front de libération du québec
s'entraînerait avec les fedayin en
jordanie à l'été 1970 cette entrevue du
journaliste pierre mado à l'effet d'une
bombe
mais que dire de l american est payé au
sommet ces deux membres du flq
s'entraînait en jordanie dans un camp du
front démocratique pour la libération de
la palestine on connaîtra que de renom
de guerre céline
[Musique]
l'interview se fait seulement en anglais
pierre nadeau travaille alors pour le
réseau anglophone au québec soit instead
of continue youtube âmes simples s ur la
mecque sélective assassination of the
leader ou co baic
il s'agit de deux autres membres du
réseau geoffroy normand roy et michel
lambert lambert a refusé de nous parler
[Applaudissements]
3 nous avons retrouvé selim c'est-à-dire
normand roy
celui ci nous a ouvert sa porte et nous
a parlé tout en refusant une entrevue à
la caméra il s'est décrit comme un
simple soldat il referait ce qu'il a
fait à l'époque si la situation
politique et elle amène le flq nous dit
il c'était des patriotes qui faisait des
choses qui devaient être faites et qui
l'ont fait avec dévotion de yoplait
hugo nous sommes normand roy nous
confirme s'être battus aux côtés des
palestiniens à l'intérieur de son casque
il avait écrit à la main je suis
québécois et dessiner une fleur de lys
avec les lettres effet le cul mais sans
son nom si je me fais sauter la tête se
disait il une trace de l'engagement d'un
québécois pour la palestine subsistera
c'est lui qui annonçait sa volonté de
tuer des lieder au québec les moyens les
plus radicaux avancé par mme marois ne
faisait pas l'unanimité dans le réseau
geoffroy dont on essayait de rocade mais
parce qu'il y avait l'an passé il était
question au cas d'assassiner des gens
jetez y ait des questions sur l'année
mais s'il avait été question de tuer
quelqu'un dit grenelle 2 n'ait pas de
dadou la pop après l'arrestation de leur
camarade qui a pas le froid michel
lambert et normand roy s'était exilé à
alger un havre pour les mouvements
révolutionnaires des années 1960
c'est là qu'ils ont formées avec
d'autres felquistes une antenne du
mouvement baptisé délégations
extérieures du flq avec l'aide
financière du fln de parti au pouvoir en
algérie
vive la révolution socialiste québécoise
et internationale
mais la pellicule
pour la révolution internationale 1970
marquent une escalade des vague
d'enlèvements surviennent au guatemala
en argentine les tupamaros précurseur de
la guérilla urbaine en amérique latine
en uruguay le mouvement des toupes à
marc os réussi quatre enlèvements dont
ceux de deux diplomates étrangers il
obtienne la libération de leurs
camarades emprisonnés
le barrage est un peu modèle s'était
déjà qui faisait des actions assez
spectaculaire sans trop de bavure
au québec cette nouvelle stratégie d
enlèvement culmine dans la crise
d'octobre
la cellule dirigée par jacques lanctôt
enlève james richard cross un diplomate
britannique
mais ça demeure par quatre hommes armés
[Musique]
dans une série de communiqués envoyés à
des stations radiophoniques les
terroristes posent leurs conditions
libération de 23 prisonniers dits
politiques qui devront être acheminées
vers cuba où l'algérie une deuxième
cellule tente d'enlever un autre
diplomate
le consul des états-unis représentant de
l'impérialisme américain
mais la surveillance policière est trop
intense ils enlèvent plus tôt le
ministre pierre laporte
la loi des mesures de guerre est
proclamée par ottawa l'armée canadienne
est déployé au québec
et si par malheur quelque chose leur
arrivait le gouvernement pourchassera
sans relâche les coupables quelques
heures plus tard c'est la tragédie
[Musique]
00h05
0.5 le coffre était finalement ouvert et
on y faisait la découverte du corps de
monsieur laporte ensanglanté la mort de
pierre laporte
on le saura plus tard aurait été en
partie accidentelle mais pour fait
propagande de celle qu annonce qu'il a
été exécuté cette violence à froid c'est
plus que les québécois n'en peuvent
accepter c'est le début de la fin
[Musique]
principalement pour placer une
libération de sorte que la maison de la
rue des récollets james ross toujours en
vie est enfin libéré les membres de la
cellule libération de jacques lanctôt
obtient un sauf conduit pour cuba l'île
de la révolution qu'ils différaient vit
depuis des années la bête est question
fidèles viennent lario par david ce à
l'aller au problème en haïti quand ils
étaient tous bons étaient aux aguets
pour votre belle étape se déplacer mais
tellement il est pauvre en fait rien ne
se passe comme dans leurs rêves dont
j'avais que cuba était une terre
d'accueil pour beaucoup de mouvements
dernier des guérillas l'amérique latine
et que une participent à des formations
de deux ordres de maniement d'armes de
techniques de guérilla urbaine
donc on voulait faire partie de ce
nouveau mal mais pour nous ça a été tu
as été refusée cuba a des objectifs
géostratégiques qui dépasse le simple
code du flq fidel castro c'est bien
qu'il ne peut pas trop encourager ce qui
se passe au québec
au risque de s'aliéner les bonnes grâces
du premier ministre canadien en 1979
pierre charette rentrer au québec
après dix ans d'exil à cuba comme tout
bon québécois avec une bouteille de rhum
condamnés pour des attentats à la bombe
il écrit en prison un récit dans lequel
il critique le régime cubain au vitriol
l'île tout entière n'était qu'un immense
camp de concentration dont les prisons
n'était que les cachots de réclusion
auxquelles étaient envoyés les plus
fortes têtes
après dix ans un pays socialiste je sais
que le communisme s'identifie et
s'identifiera toujours à la coercition
puisque c'est par elle seule qu'il peut
survivre
normand roy n'a pas gardé une meilleure
impression de la révolution algérienne
ils ont massacré plus d'algériens que de
français dit il pour les faire marcher
droit
ils ont fait pas mal plus de ça le prix
que n'importe quel autre mouvement de
résistance ou de libération mais la
désillusion fait aussi de l'intérieur du
flq marquée par un drame qui va laisser
des traces
le 29 mars 1971 le felquiste françois
mariot bachand est tué par pape dans
l'appartement où ils habitent en
banlieue de paris
c'était un des tout premiers felquistes
pendant qu'on a cru était bon faire
quelque chose pour que tous aient une
portée nationale et même internationale
son assassinat n'a jamais été élucidée
en 1997
radio canada révélait que la police
française considéré que cet assassinat
avait été l'oeuvre du groupe du flq à
alger un texte émanant de ce groupe
rédiger un mois avant le meurtre part de
la nécessité d'une épuration un de ses
auteurs raymond villeneuve est mis sur
le gril par simon du rivage ton par
d'épuration ça veut dire on s'en
débarrasse de ce colloque ont peu de
moyens on peut l'interpréter comme
formule
[Musique]
normand roy alias selim était aussi
membre du groupe at il participé à
l'exécution de mario bachand je ne peux
pas répondre à ces questions nous dit il
mais quand on évoque des gens l'associer
à un règlement de comptes au flq
il affirme n'avoir été qu'un soldat qui
a fait ce qui devait être fait est que
l'histoire jugera
l'histoire retient qu après octobre 70
c'est la fin de la violence politique ou
québec
le flq s'effondre aussi sur le plan
idéologique en 1972 pierre vallières
tourner le dos au terrorisme charles
gagnon renonce même à l'indépendance du
québec tout en restant communiste c'est
pour le meilleur choix l'indépendance
au contraire c'est un choix qui peut
conduire encore plus de 2 de difficultés
économiques sociales etc
après 1972 il ne reste pratiquement rien
du flq
seuls des graffitis appelle encore son
retour
les disciples de che guevara ont
abandonné la lutte armée
c'est une certaine vision de la
révolution qui s'éteint
des reportages de la qualité de celui
que vous venez de voir c'est exactement
pour ça qu'on va s'ennuyer notre
collègue luc chartrand mais avant de le
laisser partir à la retraite on lui fait
nos adieux tout de suite après la pause
[Musique]
en juniors de 60 ans pour que l'on ait
connu que la fraternité mais demain à
laquelle ils appartiennent
c'est évident
l'egypte
c'est un mystère
pour la première fois cette première
voir
de plus important des pays arabes est
dirigé par un islamiste
le petit mot confié l'autre jour que tu
avais choisi le métier de journaliste
pour vivre plein d'aventurés envie de
voir un extrait qui démontre quand même
donc parcours hors norme bain-marie
monde écoute cas quand j'étais jeune
puis j'ai vu nenê strong en 1969 mettre
le pied sur la lune
j'ai une grande frustration vraiment pas
ce que j'aurais voulu être là et puis
j'ai toujours voulu être là où les
choses se passent de toujours eu cette
pulsion c'est un moteur pour moi puis ça
mais c'est là m'a donné beaucoup de ça
j'étais partout du pot nord
l'afghanistan
jean pas tout énumérer mais c'est
important de dire que ce moteur
individuellement pour moi c'était
c'était ça qui m'a fait avancer
et puis ça peut être égoïste j'ai fait
beaucoup pour ça mais en même temps
c'est pas en contradiction avec
l'intérêt public parce que faire ce qui
nous intéresse c'est aussi ce qui risque
d'intéresser le public puis ce qui
intéresse le public c'est peut-être un
élément de l'intérêt public justement
alors j'ai toujours réfléchi innocence
puis même carte bifurquer vers l'
enquête toujours gardé un peu ce côté là
un peu iconoclaste cédant tour de
direction ou et où sort des élections
puis toujours à la recherche de
laventure parce que l'encaissé aussi de
l'aventuré c'est comme un grand jeu de
piste on cherche des indices on cherche
à débusquer comme son fils était un
animal en forêt on cherche à débusquer
des informations qui sont cachés ont
fait de la caméra cachée parfois c'est
stressant c'est parfois même angoissant
c'est des émotions qui sont intenses et
puissant mage 18 oui toujours recherché
puis j'étais bien servi parce que dans
ce métier là j'en ai plus que ma dose
merci pour ta passion merci pour tes
reportage lui ne manquait pas capable
merci à vous mesdames et messieurs
d'avoir été là au nom de toute l'équipe
je vous donne rendez vous
prochaine pour d'autres enquêtes
[Musique]